thank you
hey everybody and welcome to a
revelatory wild ride with Stevo a lot is
revealed in this episode let me tell you
our guest TJ Miller pan not only did he
survive brain surgery but he got really
candid about uh a lot of the struggles
that he's had and uh man it almost got
uncomfortable the guy was so candid and
willing to talk about his lowest points
that I earned a lot of respect for him
and God am I a fan I'm a real fan of TJ
Miller and I super enjoyed this it's
also the longest episode of The Wild
Ride podcast we've ever recorded I'm
reasonably sure so man get ready for a
real wild ride here now where am I well
I'm in New York City doing an
unbelievable amount of press for my book
release which was this Tuesday my book
is available everywhere
um you know I love New York City I love
the attention I love being active but I
do not love the mattress in this hotel
room God do I miss my mattress at home
from helix sleep.com
telling me I get the best night's sleep
on my mattress at home why because when
you go to helixsleep.com you take a
simple two minute quiz and it actually
pairs you with the perfect mattress for
you and your couple even better if you
go to
helixsleep.com
Stevo you get up to 200 off of any
mattress that you choose plus two free
pillows and let me tell you their
pillows are every bit as awesome as
their mattresses it's just too good to
be true you deserve a night's sleep I
bet your mattress is probably old and
disgusting it's time for a new one and
the new one should be from Helix
sleep.com slash Devo so you can get up
to 200 off of any mattress plus two free
pillows you deserve it so jump on it and
let's get into it
all right here we go
ladies and gentlemen TJ Miller yes
yeah dude yeah man hanging in New York
City while Wendy's already out of here
this is good Wendy it's like yeah New
Year talking about New York
is downstairs
she thinks this is for her she went over
and subscribing it thinks that it's dog
food but it's not we might as well get
this out of the way that's let's do it
so this is my hot sauce would you
coordinate the bag with your outfit I
did not but you know what my wife
probably did because Kate sent this and
she wrote a little card for you and me
let's check it out open that up
and I was saying to
um Scott Randolph here by the way Scott
is my co-host Scott pleasure let's
co-host the [ __ ] out of me I love it
thank you for the mangoes anytime I
bring a bag of mangoes whenever I'm
excited before you came on I was saying
to Scott you know like you think of drug
dealing like weed is selling marijuana
was the thing but then it just became
stupid to sell weed because selling
cocaine was so much more profitable
right and I feel like you and I being
you and I being hot sauce people we're
like weed guys yeah really at this point
and people get as addicted to it and
people love my hot sauce and I paired
with the guy sort of a family friend who
owned a Pepper Farm in Central Indiana
in Zionsville that's the one I want both
of us to try [ __ ] intense it's so
funny I've got Stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole I love that and then I've
got Stevo's butthole Destroyer really
yeah what I think is weird and you must
have obviously found this but I what I
think is strange is that um
all the time after shows people will be
like is this gonna make my butthole hurt
and and also the girls will be like is
this gonna just shred his [ __ ] is he
gonna be able to feel his butthole
tomorrow I'm like I didn't know that was
the objective but there you go what made
you want to get into the hot sauce game
I love hot sauce I mean I think it was
the same for you I just I put it on
everything I love it so much and this
guy just kind of
we met randomly I used to be the Mucinex
man that talking booger you know and so
I went and recorded something in the
middle of nowhere near my
mother-in-law's like horse farm and he
and I hit it off we're friends and he's
he has a Pepper Farm he was making his
own hot sauce years later he said do you
want to collaborate on Hots I said yeah
of course so I worked for about a year
and a half and we got these three and
it's Chipotle which is Smoky good flavor
not a lot of heat extreme gangster which
is your habanero that's kind of your
better than Tabasco everyday hot sauce
and then the hot one for the pepper
heads is [ __ ] intense ghost pepper
type [ __ ] and that is the one that
people are like is this gonna blow my
butthole off is my mouth gonna go
through my own [ __ ] and come around
and eat my [ __ ] head what's gonna
happen and I always say
you know this one's really hot but it's
not gimmicky hot it still has really
really good flavor so I think he had I
like that I like it but do you think
I describe myself say something I was
gonna say do you know because you went
like this
I'm holding my breath while you were
talking uh do we know the Scoville
counts of these no not exactly because
it's a little bit relative but the
[ __ ] intense what's your butthole
burning one the Destroyer all I know is
that my butthole Destroyer the top three
ingredients on the ingredients list are
the three hottest peppers on Earth ghost
pepper Carolina Reaper and uh scorpion
is that right yeah yeah and and you said
the right answer like it's relative
because it's like diluted by whatever
it's eluded by but they said ours is
roughly
I think like 750 000 to a million so
it's like anywhere in between those yeah
mine's about 749 000. so it's just it's
just below that it's gnarly and I just I
describe it as gimmicky I I describe it
as just strictly for the purpose of
being ridiculously hot like yeah
gimmicky see and so gimmicky hot which
is great that's what people want like
all the time right they're saying is
this gonna hurt my boyfriend I want to
hurt my husband right I want this to
hurt my significant other yeah
interestingly I went for as hot as we
could possibly get it to be well yeah I
would that's on brand yeah but a lot of
the feedback is even though it is like
really hot it's all so delicious have
you seen that yeah I mean people Rave
about it I'm sure and I mean that's this
it is really hot but I like ghost pepper
because it's got really good flavor and
it's a sneak attack it sneaks up on you
yeah okay where can they buy this
um on my website TJ Miller does not have
a website.com and this is my my merch
shows this and I have a line of peanut
butter but I didn't have any so I'm
going to send it to you guys all right
Los Angeles when we go on tour uh we
always ask about different people's
writers and yours comes up as like uh
they say TJ just wants you to get them
like the most [ __ ] craziest sandwich
you could possibly give me yeah I do for
a while it was a terrible turkey
sandwich and I said that was open to
interpretation and then also it was a a
either a real pinata or a hand-drawn
picture of a pinata
so that was really fun because when I
did that because I wanted to see how
much they were paying attention yeah but
also how into kind of does the club have
a sense of humor so what all the venues
started doing is each year they tried to
up their terrible turkey sandwich and
they would also compete against each
other and same with the pinata so
terrible turkey sandwich sometimes would
be like a whole roasted turkey with two
Triscuits you know in between two
triskets and they so they would do it
that big one person got me a tie the
tiniest turkey sandwich and then the
best of all I think was a pinata shaped
like a turkey sandwich and when you hit
it what came out was smaller hand-drawn
pictures of pinatas and Tiny turkey
sandwiches
that was kind of the most meta one you
know that's wow but yeah and then now I
ask for fresh flowers and then some dead
or dying flowers to remind me of my
imminent mortality and emergency
underwear
on your writer every year every single
City yeah you never know Stevo you of
all people yeah you know that emergency
underwear can come into I'm handy I I am
he likes plaid boxers
I I only wear special underwear for the
show also well I I always wear plaid
boxers because there's just some times
when your butthole's itchy you know you
don't want to Edge it but your
butthole's just on a Tans and knees just
begging you to hit you yeah and then
what is butt begging right and then when
you itch when you enter you you end up
what's called a skid mark That's why you
have a yeah I'm familiar with it the car
lots
they call it a skid mark and uh I find
that the Plaid boxers uh most
effectively disguise of the skid mark
you know you wouldn't even know it was
there you should do uh underwear with
skid marks that's like Japan
and that's something you could do but I
could yeah imagine if I was like I'm
also staring underwear it looks like
he's wiped [ __ ] on it it's called skid
mark brand underwear that's not a bad
idea yeah it's not a bad idea at all
it's like coast guards with like little
lines of coke as the art design
yeah it should be good too but right now
these skid marks is healthier for a fan
base right it's a skid mark you can make
it look really realistic too all the
different skid marks like I saw you did
that Mike Dyson Iron Man
you and I should do it we shouldn't
tattoo skin Mark diarrhea underwear on
our bodies but we try to collab then
drop that skid mark so we're gonna be
you know five aren't available no you
don't have tattoos do I have one tattoo
wow and it's I have a story about it
actually I'll just tell the story so I
went to get this tattoo
and Kate that's my wife Kate doesn't
really she's not into tattoos and I
wasn't really either but I wanted to get
one I thought of this idea so it's such
a great idea I thought
and what I did was wear my vaccine
Band-Aid was for the second vaccine shot
I just had a tattoo artist like darkened
freckles around it in that exact shape
so unless you say this is what the
tattoo is nobody can tell that it's a
tattoo okay so that's pretty clever okay
so then I um I researched to try and get
a tourist I find this girl that I really
like in San Diego and I emailed her and
I was because I talk about this right
now in my stand-up I'm talking about
being famous and my kind of famous which
you've sort of touched on a lot in your
work and so I kind of I I emailed her I
described the tattoo I said help me with
that being famous but only kind of
famous
is he famous in the way that I am famous
so you're famous in a very different way
for me but also completely different
from everybody else okay so my kind of
famous is very strange it's bad it's
good it's always so I talk about all
that and um but also you know the ways
that being famous or good is you people
will give you so I emailed to I mean all
this woman I described that tattoo and
she knows me and I say please give me a
call sincerely TJ Miller then she writes
back and she's like I don't do those
types of tattoos all right back I said I
don't think you understand what I'm
saying it's you know it's darkening for
just give me a call and I'll explain it
sincerely TJ Miller and then she wrote
back she goes no no I'm all booked up
you can forget it you know good luck so
email back one more time but this time
I'm DJ Miller God damn it better than
that I sign it sincerely TJ Miller from
the Emoji Movie okay and so right away
she writes back immediately because it's
so random but if this is really TJ
Miller call me and I did and she
recognized my voice because my voice is
very recognizable right so the music man
and all kinds of other things and she
was our kids are a big fan of big hero6
and how to train your dragon so I go but
as I'm in the chair
he's got the needle in my arm she's like
I totally thought you're trolling me and
I was like what what do you mean she
goes I just I thought you're [ __ ]
with me I thought there's no way you're
TJ Miller and I was like why would I
she's like that's what I thought like
why would anyone pretend to be TJ Miller
and I was like yeah I don't know
sometimes
your go-to from the Emoji movie I mean
yeah the list of stuff that was that was
what I thought I'm like wow so the the
Emoji pick up Stevo from TV the movie
it's like you wouldn't that that's not
your emoji movie was a big deal well
it's you know kids love it but for me
it's what's funniest like for a long
time Yogi Bear 3D was that's what I
wanted people to introduce me with wow
when I went on stage and for me stand-up
comedy is like so much more important to
me than anything else in terms of Comedy
what do you think I love it it's great
right I want more of it
um You Gotta Have It and um and so for a
long time it was ladies and gentlemen
from Yogi Bear 3D TJ Miller which is the
best film that I've ever been in it was
my best performance I gave myself a
Critics Choice Award for best uh best
supporting actor and a talking bear
comedy certain
um that's a children's movie Yogi Bear
3D yeah I hope so okay good so then
after a while that got like a little
stale's introducement so that I did this
movie Transformers for Age of Extinction
it's an indie film it did really well in
Sundance I don't know if you've got
Transformers
no no it's Michael uh Michael Bay and
it's um it's Michael Bay Michael Bay
does not Mark Wahlberg movies no it's
great it's only two hours too long
you're gonna love it you'll see it and
uh and so then I started introducing
having people introduce me like that and
then after a while that got kind of so
then the Emoji movie They Came to me to
ask me if I would do it and I was like
of course I went in I looked at all the
boards and saw it I thought it would be
so great and they also would let me do a
pass on the script all this stuff but I
did it because it's so funny to be in a
movie called Yogi Bear 3D where the 3D
is in the name of the movie yeah and
then the Emoji Movie just tells you what
it's about right like I just thought
that was so dumb that they'd be like
what movie are you the Emoji Movie
what's what do you think ing like what's
the elevator pitch for
yeah like I'll give it to you ready yeah
it's a movie about emojis
did you like that was that too fast I
mean what floor are we going in the
elevator if it's a time for a ride then
I'll tell you this yeah
emojis the main character in emoji goes
through an entire character Arc where he
ends up being a different Emoji wow
Emoji Movie take my money please how
much do you want for this movie you made
a hundred million dollars domestic so it
was a huge success we hold the record
for the fastest animated movie
development to production to Premiere
wow
emojis it's all emojis yeah all right so
the animation looks pretty good but so
that was sort of funny for me so that's
my kind of joke and then she was like
okay this can't be the real TJ Miller
and then as soon as I said Emoji Movie
she was like maybe it is and then it was
yeah I was not you know I was pretending
to be TJ Miller who would why would
anyone do that right who would do that I
I thought that when you said she thought
you were trolling her that it was the
tattoo idea that she thought she was
being trolled with like who would who
would want freckles darkened like
controlling me what's hilarious is that
that's the dumbest idea for tattoo of
all time for sure but even more
Preposterous would be pretending to be
teaching though right that's even more
ridiculous than that tattoo idea all
right yeah I mean so that's my only
tattoo
and uh I don't think I'm gonna get
another one I'm gonna get it darkened
when I'm filming my next special in San
Diego on uh in March I mean how many
tattoos do you have do you even know
it's a subjective number I mean like uh
some have grown so you know like haven't
been removed it's not been removed have
you had a lot removed no I used to have
my Knuckles said [ __ ] and [ __ ]
yeah because there's a time when you
kind of grow out of that one I think you
know what I never grow out of is being
an attention [ __ ] even if I wanted to I
couldn't but all this attention whoring
that I've been doing in New York City to
promote my book has kept me so busy that
my hair is growing out of my face I'm
telling you man do I have this gray
stubble all over what man I'm hurting
for a shave and thank God I've got my
Harry's shaving products to take care of
it you know normally when my stubble is
this grown out like I would be afraid of
using uh a razor because of my tug on it
it's not my Harry's baby they stay sharp
these five blade razors are not only
incredible but they're affordable no
gimmicks no nonsense no it doesn't
vibrate it doesn't light up it's just
what I need and it's what I love man
I've been using Harry's for years and
I'm never turning back plus
man when I go after this it's going to
Glide right through it
no problem and you should try it because
they got the starter kit with the five
blade razor the weighted ergonomic
handle the travel case to protect the
razor the foaming shave gel and the
travel size body wash all of this put
together the starter kit is worth 16
bucks by their measure I told you
they're affordable high quality but this
16 value starter kit is yours for only
three dollars man these people are
generous to the listeners of the Wild
Ride podcast and don't look a gift horse
in the mouth they're offering you this
good of a deal you jump on it by going
to harrys.com
Stevo again for this starter kit with
all this great stuff everything you need
16 value it's all yours for just three
bucks if you go to Harry
series.com slash Stevo jump on that deal
and let's get back to talking about
these dumb tattoos
right I know when you're giving your
first trip uh christening baby
christening and you're the one doing it
your circumcision I guess right now you
don't really want to say [ __ ] [ __ ] right
why did you get that book
um that's a follow-up question why in
the [ __ ] did you end up doing that
I mean I was intensely proud these were
right I I don't I was like shut the [ __ ]
stupid [ __ ]
and then he apologizes in the most
sincere way five minutes later
but I mean so I'm kind of the opposite
and people I think think that I am
um I think they just want me to insult
them because so many things that I've
done in Deadpool the whole run of me
insulting Ryan Reynolds all through
Silicon Valley I was always insulting so
I think people think of the yell stuff
out though and it happened more it's
happened less now that I've become I
guess more famous or people are just
like don't that that's not okay to
around you used to happen all the time
every single show
but now yeah if people yell they kind of
want to be involved and I'm very quick
because I started out as an improviser
I'm quick to go into the crowd to talk
to people and that's what's so weird
about this special dear Jonah because I
did this I have these specials that are
coming out that are all completely
improvised stand up so it's where the
audience gives suggestions for names of
jokes and that's my set list and then I
they I have a projector and they throw
up the name it could be whatever like
Karl Marx farts or something like that
and the first time I see it is the first
time the audience sees it and then I
turn around and do a joke completely
improvised right off that and I finish
they threw up the next joke and so I
started as an improviser that's really
fun for me are you committing yourself
to putting this out like regardless of
how it goes yeah totally well and what
you do is you get rid of the stuff that
absolutely didn't work but yeah you have
to have some things that show you
fumbling and not doing well right but
for the most part the audience is just
amazed that you can even and do it in
general right present something so when
it's really funny then they're just like
what the [ __ ] just I'm amazed and um but
I do a lot of crowd work I speak with
the audience I'll I talk about my day I
have a lot of stuff online that's kind
of I show up in Winnipeg and just talk
about Winnipeg and what happened that
morning and it's just it's all
improvised the audience loves it so I
love to throw that stuff up but in dear
Jonah the strangest thing happened which
is so when you film a special you know
this when you film a special you have to
do two different shows usually there's
two different shows at theater or
something and then you pick the best one
and then use that as the foundation and
you patch up any little issues with the
other show so I figured out a way to
shoot these specials so that they're
television quality but I can shoot four
shows or five shows so I did four shows
in Nashville
and the first show went pretty well
we're like ah we don't have it at all
it's just me warming up and then the
second show you know Late Show Friday
sometimes you're like oh this is gonna
be a disaster people are so drunk and
also it is the worst and people are so
drunk uh in Nashville so I said
if I get out there and they're just a
mess I'm just gonna riff and we'll have
that on and the director said no no
honestly we don't really have it at all
so just do the exact special again and
hopefully we get a couple of good things
then we'll we'll Bank those I said we'll
see what happens
so I go out and I start performing and
it's the best audience it's such an
amazing audience I'm like how is this
possible that SEC somehow it felt like
these people had drank perfectly they
were absolutely all professional drunks
which is I guess Nashville it's either a
bachelorette party or just Pro drunkards
and I'm performing and I'm like this is
it this is special I mean this this is
the audience that I want for the special
and then this [ __ ] guy in the front
row starts just talking and I was like
ah why is this guy heckling and it was
weird you know how when you're really
drunk but you have audience members that
are drunk and they're not trying to be
mean or anything they're just drunk in a
way that they forget there's other
people and it's just Stevo and them in
their living room and they're listening
and so they'll just talk to you and so
he started doing that he's like Ah
that's true yeah yeah oh yeah no that
makes sense yeah good that was good and
I was just like God damn it so I ignored
him for a little while because he's
[ __ ] up the special I mean he's
talking about he's brought he was
frontistro he was the most front he's
practically on the [ __ ] stage really
his he could have leaned his chin down
and he was on the stage right there so
it's like all right what am I gonna do
I've got to just talk to him I'm gonna
try and shut him down
and then I'm gonna move on you know and
then get back into what I want to do
which is film this special that I it was
going to be called the pandemic special
to show people what I was doing during
the pandemic right and it's it's
particularly difficult when you're doing
crowd work on camera to pull in anything
from another show because you've got
different audience members and for the
rest of the show if you call back to
that person you can't you can only use
that thing in that show so yeah you're
totally [ __ ] kind of so I said all
right I'm just going to talk to him get
done and move on
and so he's right in the front row so
he's wearing cargo pants and I go oh
you're wearing cargo pants what kind of
cargo you got what do you what do you
call it what's your Freight you know and
he starts to talk about cargo pants and
he's like I I I I just like cargo pants
even though I don't
keep anything in them and so it's
immediately clear he's developmentally
challenged this guy is like you know
yeah he is not he's not a drunk Heckler
let me put it that way that is not what
was happening right and so there's this
moment where he finishes that thing and
you can feel the audience is like what
is TJ gonna do because the real moment
am I gonna lots of comedians would just
be like
I like cargo pants you could absolutely
have done that but that's not me and so
I just took a beat and I just turned the
audience and I'm like I want all of you
to know that I am not going to make fun
of him at all and they just erupt
everyone's laughing and clapping and
stuff because then everyone can just
relax and this this kid can relax too
and then throughout the show he starts
to come back in I like ask him some
question I do this at one point he just
I say so it's quiet and he's like
hilarious it's hilarious and I was like
it is hilarious and as The Show Goes On
he becomes more and more incorporated
into it until by the end of the show by
the other special he's kind of the star
of it and so I changed the name of it
from the pandemic special to Dear Jonah
because it sort of ended up being a love
letter to this guy who I'm sure and he's
the hugest fan of mine he just loves me
and he says that a couple times in the
show and the the closer of the show I
involve him and there's this guy who's a
total idiot [ __ ] this guy named
Trevor which is the perfect name for
this dude when you see the special and
you know I mean it's you got to see it
but it's unlike anything else because no
one's ever had something like this
happen and even if they did they would
cut it out probably right they would
move away from it right which is
hilarious because now there's this whole
ableist thing and they're saying you
can't say spaz and all those sorts of
things and so a lot of people said to me
well you shouldn't probably cut down I
was like why would I cut that out that's
able That's not including I want to
include him in the conversation he was
the show he ended up being the best part
of the show and so that was the craziest
experience for me of a Heckler right
because I thought I was being heckled
and turns out being something completely
different and so throughout the whole 45
minute special you're just like you kind
of halfway through sir be like where's
Jonah I want to see Jonah do some stuff
again and then he does it's amazing yeah
if only I had hecklers like that I've
just got absolute [ __ ] oh I've got
those too and then you just gotta tear
them apart and I get some really
entitled white women yelling [ __ ] and
getting upset at me that's actually in
the special also but um yeah usually you
gotta shut them down and make fun of
them my technique always is to like
contextualize their behavior like
recontextualize so somebody will be like
wasn't that funny or something like that
oh my God you would be a great dad you
know what I mean somebody comes back
with their look Dad look what I drew
today not that good I gotta give you a
beer and get the [ __ ] out of the way of
the television so you kind of you know
you get it right that angle sort of but
this was a great example of how I do
crowd work but it also kind of shows
that I'm a good guy I think you know
there's some people are like oh he seems
like an [ __ ] and it's really you can
tell on the special that like all I want
is for this to go well for this kid yeah
forever and it's it ends up being so
great he showed up at 4 P.M he's the
first person in line biggest fan and
that's what he was sitting this close to
this stage because he got there and I I
thought he was with his family and I
later found out that they were just
people at his table who would befriend
him that his family had dropped him off
and that he had seen me before
found this out afterwards and he uh was
in the back of the room and he liked it
so much that he decided in his mind I
like him so much I'm gonna sit as close
as possible as I can and they also the
the uh venue zany is the comedy club
they said
um that he asked can I get closer to the
stage how actually physically close can
I get to the stage so it's amazing it's
like such a bizarre thing that happened
and that that could have happened any
single night of my life as a performer
any of the hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of shows I do and it just
happened to be on the night that I had a
six camera shoot and was filming the
audience so we caught everything from
him it's pretty it's pretty special
pretty awesome yeah people say they tear
up at the end of it some people are like
it's almost because it's like emotional
at the end you're like it's great yeah
you gotta check it out says that that
that's epic you said when uh you walked
in and we had not yet started recording
that uh that you have a story about us
meeting and let me tell you that when I
when I hear this when I when when I hear
that somebody has an old story about
meeting me it gives me great anxiety
because you just give it to me you go I
bet you can't suck your own dick and
then you started sucking your own dick
and as I tried to do it you hit me over
the head with like a sack of potatoes
and it forced my dick into my own mouth
and then I found out the jerk
your dick was prosthetic and you were
just joking but I had sucked my own dick
by the end of the night meeting you so
you don't need to have any anxiety where
was this in Vegas yeah I don't know so
what actually happened was we and my
wife Kay was with me yeah
I say that because
um
I get anxiety because there have been
different versions of me and and if you
met a certain version of me then the
story is going to be horrifying I think
that's true I always wish
that I had met nitrous oxide you okay
because I was a huge nitrous oxide
enthusiasts were you for years we did I
did the Critics Choice Awards
it's just a long time ago and I was
doing so much nitrous at that point that
I would go on live television do what I
was doing then run back look on my notes
hit a couple of nitrous cartridges and
then go back on stage because my joke
about nitrouses would only lasts like 20
30 seconds would be the best thing to
get pulled over doing because the cops
like if you've been doing nitrous and
you're like yeah a little bit but what
are you gonna do about it because now
it's over
that's it it's all gone right it only
lasts 20-30 seconds or as long as you
keep inhaling it right exactly well and
that's why after critic Swiss Awards we
went we went to the Bel Air and Kate and
I just partied we knew each other since
College we've known each other for like
20 some years and so we just sometimes
we just go into that mode and we just
partied and we were so excited and when
we woke up the next day there were like
a thousand whippet cartridges because we
had bought the hundred packs you know so
we just did you guys are like hundreds
and hundreds and hundreds that night and
we was joking there's a whole like bar I
don't know how we ordered it but it was
a full bar on a room service cart like I
guess we just been like bring it all
damn it bring every last one of them and
we just and so Kate woke up and she was
like oh man we gotta stop doing nitrous
and like as she said that I was like oh
I found another 100 back and she's like
after that
gotta stop doing nitrous right after we
finish that but I think we we met you in
incredibly
uh grateful amiable
authentic Stevo because you really
quickly kind of said oh man I'm a huge
fan and I just I love doing stand-up and
it's kind of new to me but it's a while
ago it's at the Laugh Factory okay and
so I kind of I thought that was amazing
and it was a great moment for me because
you know there's a lot of people that
didn't start up a stand-up comics and
they started doing stand-up comedy like
a Jeremy Piven or a lot of YouTube guys
and a lot of comics or were just like oh
God yeah sure you're doing stand-up but
the way that you talked about it just in
our brief interaction I realized no this
guy has a lot of respect for the form
and then later subsequently as I sort of
heard your stuff and came to understand
I realized you really were a Storyteller
but you were also kind of doing that as
stand up and doing stand-up within that
and I feel like I saw all that on you
like in you right away and then you were
so nice to Kade and then you talk to
Kate's cousin Giselle who's just [ __ ]
awesome she's like a goth mom right now
and she and her husband's so great too
and she's a huge fan of yours and so you
blew her [ __ ] mind because she
expects you so nervous to me and she
expects you'd be like oh it's nice to
meet you and yeah I'm Stevo and I gotta
go and you just straight up stood there
for 10 minutes kind of answering
questions and asking about her life and
all this stuff and she'll she'll never
forget that I mean it was the coolest
thing and that's the other thing I
noticed about you I was like yeah this
guy will definitely take 10 minutes of
his time to permanently alter somebody's
life in terms of their stories and who
they you know because there's a thing
never meet your Heroes I just saw you
kind of being like if you meet me and
I'm your hero you're gonna get as much
of me as I can give you well sometimes
it's a man
yeah sometimes I can probably get you in
trouble because you're such a nice dude
you'll sort of give almost too much
yourself that happens to me a lot and it
can get you in trouble but for the most
part with fans because we've had some
crazy evil fans but we also have heard
so many people come to me and to K and
say it's just so amazing meeting you
guys or I met you you know you performed
in our college and afterwards it's like
15 years ago and afterwards I came up to
you and I was like what's up and you're
like come on let's [ __ ] chug Dr
Pepper I need sandwiches as fast as we
possibly can they're like I'll never
forget that so that was that was I met
that Stevo so what would you call that
Stevo different versions of you what was
that one that sounds like uh uh um a
fresh
you know restored Stevo because I'm
thinking that the last episode of this
podcast was with Wee Man and I was
discussing with him about how yeah I was
discussing with him about how you know
despite the fact that we've been around
for over 20 years you know kind of in
the public eye yeah for sure that having
this this uh most recent Jackass movie
come out it really kind of was great by
the way it's crazy thank you it
re-energized the brand and uh and it
really made it
um considerably more challenging to get
around in public you know there's just
more like we do there's more energy
around us before that did you feel you
could walk around and people wouldn't
bother you I mean it's he's rid of us no
in L.A yeah in like Nebraska Walmart
yeah I mean like of course what would be
interesting is that weird how you're
famous in different ways in different
places yeah but I mean it's it's been a
challenge to get around in public for
for 20 years no doubt but it's just been
I would characterize it as overwhelming
as of late and uh and it makes um
it's just been more difficult it's it's
that when there's more uh energy when
there's more people more you know
attention it's harder to give everybody
that special moment you know it's harder
to give and and it's it's it's
more like you you get burned out you're
not a fresh version of yourself and like
when there's just so many people all the
time like I've found myself getting kind
of short it's like yes I'll take a
picture of it put it on selfie and hurry
up you know yeah and you know I do the
same thing with somebody you mentioned
that because today I'm on the phone with
Kate I'm trying to get this [ __ ] hot
sauce here because I forgot
but I love that one the best all right
you guys are hot hot sauce guys right so
then there you go we're sexy hot sauce
guys right but did you read did you read
the card from Kate sexy hot sauce guys
just read the card that's on the back
Kate wrote this I didn't even tell her
okay
good luck hot pants don't sit in there
because she loves the thing where you're
going in the pool I love it but yeah I I
was trying to talk to Kate and trying to
get the hot sauce here and um
you know this guy comes hey can I take a
picture with you and I'm and you do
you're kind of like yeah yeah quickly
I'm on the phone with my wife and
they're like I'm so sorry I'm so sorry
and you're like no that's not what I
need I don't need to be sorry yeah
that's just and so I don't even ask him
to put on selfie I take the phone I know
enough about Androids now and I'm so I
flip it take the picture really quickly
and you don't want to brush them off
right because they're huge fans but you
also have your life so it's a balance
right right you do mean greets at your
shows I used to before
um
I used you're very famous for this by
the way it means a lot to me that I've
developed a good reputation for the way
I am on the road and you know what
deserves a good reputation my butthole
because it's clean as a whistle because
I keep it so and I do that very very
effectively at home with my tushy bidet
from hello
tushy.com now if you've never used a
bidet let me tell you you're out of your
mind and your butthole is disgusting why
because with my bidet from
hellotushy.com I twist that knob and
I've got the most refreshing stream of
water just power blasting my sphincter
completely clean like clean enough to
eat off okay and it just feels so good
when I get done blasting my butthole
with that powerful dream of water coming
out of my tushy bidet that I reach down
or wipe my butthole just to dry it and
the satisfaction of looking at that
toilet paper and seeing no poo poo on it
it's meaningful plus barely use any
toilet paper because all I'm doing is
just drying the water off of my
perfectly clean poop shoot and
saves the environment because you're not
just going through toilet paper like a
maniac no no no no no a nice refreshing
Blast from the tushy bidet now here's
the thing not only do I love this
company but it's my favorite sponsor of
the Wild Ride podcast
hellotushy.com and they are generous as
well go to
hellotushy.com
Stevo for 10 off of your entire order
and free shipping plus if you feel like
really taken care of of your pooper then
they got the tushy Ace I mean dude
that's a whole seat it warms up it's got
a remote control you can warm up the
water that you're blasting your butthole
with like they've got the whole range of
products and they're my favorite
products that I've ever promoted on this
podcast again hello
tushy.com
Stevo 10 off your whole order plus free
shipping right right now not to mention
a butthole that is clean enough to eat
off so get to it and let's get back to
it
I used to for uh
um before the pandemic and I kind of
stopped and now I sort of do them at
will like if I like an audience then
I'll mention it I'll say if you buy some
hot sauce I'll come take a picture with
you but you're famous for like every
single person you're so retired with
every single person they've said that
they've been like the only person that
does meet and greets as much as you
Stevo and then I think they said Carlos
Mencia does them but then also just goes
into the audience and he has just three
hours on stage right yeah three in the
morning there's only four people left
anyway exactly I was on The Comedy Club
Circuit all three of us 11 years I was
in comedy clubs every show at the last
thing I said was I'm gonna take a photo
with every single one of you guys who
wants one the whole audience and then um
since the pandemic I've graduated to
theaters and now it's like a thousand
people I can't do that so um so yeah we
just do like a smaller group of uh meet
and greet here looks like you got to buy
the meet and greet pass and then I do
all those well and you know what's
interesting about that is that some
people are like ah man you used to do
it's like no
because if you're if you if the person
is paying eighty dollars for the meet
and greet and knows there's only gonna
be 10 people or whatever then
that's important for them because
basically what they're paying for is
like I want to guarantee time for my
wife to meet you yeah I'm trying to
impress my girlfriend I mean or this is
like the Christmas present to my husband
right so I want him to have some time
with you so there's a good aspect of
that too right you know it's not just
like oh he's charging an arm and a leg
to meet him but yeah I mean you know
that's I don't know that that is kind of
what uh that's the conundrum for guys
like you and me I think because you want
to give the person everything but you
can't give so much of yourself that I
also thought it was interesting I mean
I'm not wearing a hat or anything but do
you just walk around without sunglasses
and a hat on or anything yeah because
that's what Judy this morning so that
must be tough too because it doesn't
have recognizable I I could wear glasses
and a hat doesn't I I could wear full
clown makeup I'm still gonna get
recognized you know what that's actually
two things that you just brought up that
I wanted to talk to you about one you
get recognized by your voice yeah right
so then the same thing so our Dynamic
didn't do [ __ ] right because you and I
were in the people like is that Stevo
and then you drive it's like boom for
sure and then the other thing I was
going to talk to you about is that you
used to be a clown that you started out
as a clown and I went to Circus School
in like Paris France and I also I'm a
juggler I know we understand we're told
that you juggle during your stand-up
yeah I have a special coming out next
year called philosophy circus
and there's yeah there's like juggling
there's terrible ventriloquism somebody
in the audience plays the trombone like
it's like very circus and this is
already shot yeah that's right wow I
shot two hour-long specials in three
weeks two completely separate specials
because I was like we got to get these
done and then move on to the San Diego
special and get that ready I gotta stop
preparing with to shoot specials that
I'm ready to shoot
um but I love circus that's why I love
jackass so much because it has a lot of
elements of circus and when I read that
about you I was like oh that makes
perfect sense yeah because circus is
like don't think just love just laugh
just be amazed just yeah and that's what
I love about circus and I really always
thought of Jackass like similar to a
circus and nobody ever brings that up
because they just don't think of that
connection but that's great because you
are a clown I'm a clown also but we're
sort of not traditional clowns right
which you would think of when you think
of clown for sure so uh what what kind
of juggling do you do juggle balls so I
could do that I can juggle up to five
balls but in wow the leap from four to
five is a substantial leap and they
called the black belt of juggling as if
you can do five then you're like a
master dragon you do I can do it like
when you're juggling four balls all that
means is you're just doing two any
chance
everybody watching is like oh my God but
yeah jump to five is really different
you can do five I've never gotten
anywhere near five I had to just do it I
was actually at a circus camp as a
counselor teaching stilt walking and
juggling and every day I would just go
and practice for like five hours six
hours how long can you sustain five
balls for a while I can get through the
pattern for like yeah for like a couple
minutes but not I couldn't do it in
perpetuity I'm gonna drop one eventually
right so what you do when you juggle
five is you hit it right until it's
impressive and then you catch them and
you're like I'm done I could have done
it forever
uh but what I juggle is I juggle them
you know flaming I can juggle torches
knives can you pass clubs okay pass
clubs yeah but my favorite thing and
what's in a special is cigar boxes okay
so those are the three blocks that you
move around sure that's really cool I'm
very good at those I'm actually a member
of The Magic Castle in Los Angeles wow
nice because of that because WC Fields
popularize that and then I can also do
these things called Shaker cups which is
like apps that stack and you do all that
so those are the actually the two types
of um that's exactly how you do it yeah
yeah same way you jack off a bunch of
guys
uh and so um those are the ones that I
find really interesting but in the
philosophy circus I juggle glow in the
dark balls I tell a scary story to
everybody and then uh I do been it's so
bizarre but I do have ventriloquist
dummy bit at the end of dear Jonah and
then just because I I had to change it
to that for the pandemic then
um I did a there's a ventriloquist dummy
bit at the end of philosophy circus so
it's really funny to me that when people
say when people see this next special
after dear Jonah they're gonna be like
is he gonna start closing every special
with a ventriloquist dummy thing is that
like who he is but it's not it's just
those two work so well in these specials
so all right yeah yeah yeah but that's
crazy so did you do were you did you not
get into clown college for Ringling
brothers or you did I did you really did
yeah that's what I wanted to do after
high school it was tough to get in it
was a big deal and they ended the
program correct I graduated in 2000. I
graduated in the last class ever which
was the class of 1997. so I I was
graduating in 99 and I would have
applied in 98 but it was over that's
amazing yeah I'm so jealous of you for
that thing alone yeah it's not all the
ball stuff you went to Paris to go to
Circus school yeah so that's what I
ended up having to do but that was in
college and I got a um
I got a scholarship to that so I just
had to get myself there so you're like
[ __ ] I can't get in the Ringling
Brothers Circus so then you went to
Paris yeah so but I would have rather
done an American clown college this was
great but mostly in Paris I learned
still walking and it was more like body
movement French Cirque du Soleil type
[ __ ] I wanted to just do like hit
yourself on the head with a giant
inflatable Sledgehammer fall down and
get in the car like that that American
clowning I think is really interesting
because it's more jackassy yeah it's
more Three Stooges a little bit you know
why'd you get it why I know you've
talked about it before but like you
wanted to go in it for the art of the
circus why did you want to go into the
circus I had my heart set on becoming a
crazy famous stunt man you know it
started it started out as a
skateboarding led me to the video camera
I was like
I'm not going to be a professional
skateboarder I'm not that good but I
love making videos I'm just want to be
crazy with my if I just found really
crazy crap with my home video camera I
want that to be my career yeah yeah
which is crazy because there was no
precedent for that and and that somehow
we made I made it work but um the uh
the idea was like I'm gonna be a stunt
man and and I wasn't getting any
traction and then while living with my
sister and my sister found out about
clown college like like uh it occurred
to me I was like okay well maybe people
will take me more seriously as a
stuntman if I'm a trained circus
professional it was like a sort of a
means to an end I was trying to I only
went to clown college to further my goal
of becoming a famous crazy professional
stunt man so that was sort of your back
door way into being a motorcyclist in
the globe or those stuff
if that was gonna be it perhaps I just
wanted to be taken more seriously for
lighting myself on fire at backyard keg
parties
I love that and the way to do that the
validation of your experiences was the
clown right yeah I'm the only guy who
went to clown college seeking legitimacy
I think that's it that's exactly right
for sure oh my God that's so funny yeah
I mean you had to like act to the public
like I mean
they are expressions where did you study
they broke it down they broke clown
cards down into like you know hour-long
classes that went throughout the day so
you had like an hour of dance class you
had an hour uh like whatever like uh all
kinds of dance you had uh an hour of uh
out of acrobatics you know an hour of
skills you know and an hour of a circus
history you know you'd put on your
makeup for for it I'd be an hour of
makeup like um every day you would do
this yeah so it's like class but like
the wow those are the places yeah
there's legit classes would break for
lunch for an hour we'd go back to more
classes so can you really dance no
now you you never you didn't the only
thing that you had to do uh was to walk
on stilts you had to be proficient still
Walker beyond that it was just sort of
an exercise in trying to to uh just
highlight your strengths yeah find your
clown right you're trying to figure out
what your clown was going to be right is
there like a defined different types of
clown like a type of clown yeah for sure
but what kind of clown are you or what
kind of clown are you well there's three
distinct types of clown there's
um like for lack of a better word the
the hobo clown which is like Emmett
Kelly that's right yeah you know that
that's sort of its own kind of clown and
then there's ramp they call that
sometimes yeah and then and then the
other two is the white face clown and
the Auguste Clown and and they base this
on um cartoon characters like Tom and
Jerry there's uh like one is like you
know Tom is the cat he's like dumb like
runs into the wall and Jerry's like the
straight face like more kind of like
clever you know like in all the cartoons
there's the the the the straight one and
there's the dumb one that like crashes
into the wall all the time so I was the
dumb one that crashes into the wall all
the time that's perfect it's called the
August clown and then the white face
clown is gonna be like your Jerry so
when you see like a bunch of clowns
acting out all of them are acting out
one of three different characters uh uh
traditional subversions yeah they would
sort of say is you'd say okay whatever
but find your clown your yours would be
like there's also the archetype the
butthole burner but and that's just
someone who has their butthole burning
the whole time
that type of thing yeah um no but you
find kind of what are your strengths
like you were saying and then you kind
of plug that into what your clown would
be I I I would say and in different
different countries is different Russian
clowns are different than French clowns
or different American clowns but it does
all kind of come to those three yeah I
would submit too that there's also like
just straight skills clowns you know
like you could be a clown and just your
deal is just that you're gonna juggle
the whole time you think you can start a
clown college school and teach all the
classes I wouldn't want to do that and
yeah but you could you could right I
suppose I I you can write a curriculum
I I could but uh I out of respect for
the art I don't think that I think would
be interesting is for you to kind of
teach stunt clowning
perhaps you know but I I think when I
was just blown away by is that knowing
that I can see so much of that in your
work and it's a way to kind of go back
and look at his [ __ ] from the past and
see the way he reacts to the camera and
when he actually gets hurt how he sort
of expresses that it's really I mean
it's really really interesting because I
just I didn't know that about you until
just recently once I found out that I
was maybe coming on the podcast and so I
I we I read that and it just clicked I
was like of course he's a clown that
makes perfect sense and that's you know
coming from a clown so yeah I I worked
as a clown like that that uh my clown
career afforded me the ability to not
sell drugs for a living yeah I went from
from selling a terribly short
underweight bags of weed to earning a
legitimate living as a clown right up
until the day that uh I was shooting the
jackass series actually as a matter of
fact I uh washed off my clown makeup in
the circus for the very last time within
a half an hour of barfing up the
goldfish in the iconic goldfish yeah oh
my God Knoxville in the MTV crew
actually came to film me perform in the
circus for what turned out to be my last
ever performance in the circus and uh we
went straight from there to do they have
that footage yeah yeah I think they even
showed that footage in that uh demise
and Rise documentary about my downward
spiral into addiction that would be cool
footage to grab your last footage as a
clown yeah they I did a simultaneous
fire breathing backflip off the top rung
of a stepladder really I don't think I
landed it particularly cleanly but yeah
that's so great yeah I think in
everything that I do if you know that
I'm a clown then you see the movies I've
been in especially Ehrlich from Silicon
Valley is a very clown he's very false
Staffing oh my gosh you know and so you
see him when he knocks stuff over the
way that I interact with stuff we're
talking about the faga yogurt it's just
uh all of that kind of comes back down
to clown and in that I gained weight for
that movie and I created a clown wig
with my hair and so it if you look at
that character now knowing that it's
supposed to be clown you're like oh that
makes perfect sense personally I would
have thought that uh when you sent the
email about the tattoo that you'd say TJ
Miller from Silicon Valley
I know but that's not funny
that would have been like hey I'm a
celebrity you should let me know okay so
it's kind of the irony of it is that
yeah that I'm saying the Emoji movie
instead of Silicon Valley instead of
Deadpool right out of office Christmas
party instead of the indie film
Transformers for Age of Extinction yeah
it's pretty good I'm South by Southwest
that's uh that's quite the body of work
man it's uh yeah she's out of my league
right Cloverfield all the way to
unearned water yeah I'm into it's
incredible so you've got to have a you
know a nice little Nest Egg tucked away
the pandemic really screwed me you
probably didn't screw you guys at all we
saw this podcast during the pandemic
really like I I the during the pandemic
which was smart can you pass me some of
my own hot sauce yeah really hot stuff
and then and then we opened up a
fulfillment house because the e-commerce
started taking off yeah we uh we we
turned our attention more towards
e-commerce and podcasting and even more
like digital content and that allowed us
to kind of expand our shirt touring
touring Mallet out
uh but but yeah no the pandemic worked
well for us
yeah I kind of I yeah we have a an essay
but um I really love performing so I was
wholly focused on performing right and
then the other stuff that I would do was
acting and so just everything kind of
shut down right it was such a bummer but
like I mentioned Kate and I met in
college so it really was cool for the
four months of lockdown here in New York
because it was just like college like
all we did was get drunk watch movies
not do homework and try and score
Percocet but not be able to guilt-free
it was exactly like that right exactly
um but then I got back to touring almost
as soon as I possibly did it before most
other comedians it was just me and black
Comics that were playing the clubs did
you
um do any of the drive-in movie theater
[ __ ] or no I was thinking about it and
then like
I also didn't do
I also didn't do any um
I didn't do like any
Zoom shows or anything like that yeah
because I was like I can't do that so I
did you do drive-in movie shows ah I did
not no I just didn't want I I hold so
sacred
that kind of real performance in the
comedy club in the theater like right
there and happening
and so I didn't want to mess with that
other stuff so no I didn't do any of
that right
um and that probably hurt me I'm sure I
could have made a little bit of money
but it just wasn't worth it they were
charging obnoxious ticket prices for
that Drive-In business for sure but I
just thought it it almost kind of was
sad and it would just remind you of what
was going on so as soon as I could
actually go to these places
I went I could only I talk about it in
dear Jonah the only thing I could do the
only place I could perform were the
crazy places that were like this shit's
not real so I performed in like um
Phoenix was pretty Arizona was crazy
crazy but you're right I was doing uh
Arizona and like Oklahoma was uh pretty
doors yeah I took all this in the
special that's exactly right but it was
like Tampa Florida and like Greensboro
North Carolina and Orlando Florida and
like Houston Texas and Naples Florida
and like Port Charlotte Florida
everywhere in the UFC
and Miami Florida and it was just
basically all in Florida but I went
because I said to myself never before
has been more important than what I do
because people are so sad they're so
scared even if they're pretending not to
be so I went but I would have to go
do the shows come back totally
quarantine for my wife and then go get a
Cova test like two days did you ever get
sick with coven not during not until I'm
a crime okay and I had two fans on stage
two like blowing towards the audience if
they cough the they laugh the covet I
mean I can just blow it right back in
their [ __ ] face and um
did you get sick on a macron or yeah but
what do you mean did I actually get six
yeah no symptoms at all right so it was
Ninja but I had vaccine and boosted but
for like many many months I only spent
the night with Kate one night a week
the rest of the time I was just jacking
and attacking it downstairs I love that
watching Stevo videos you know what I
mean
yeah dude so the uh I remember like a
few years ago it was like like there was
stories about you like crazy stuff and I
remember getting the impression like man
it seems like TJ Miller is in trouble
with alcohol or something like that and
uh I was like I remember feeling like
concerned for you and then that concerns
kind of like went away because there
hasn't been any stories like that well
and what's interesting and I'm I want to
talk about this probably in March
but I have a brain condition
he is not kidding about the brain
condition wow is this about to get
intense plus the train incident I mean I
think everybody heard about it it was
awkward to bring it up but I had to my
journalistic Integrity would have been
shot if I didn't bring up the train
incident I had to much like I have to
stay hydrated or I'm gonna die so the
coolest way that you can possibly stay
hydrated and save the environment at the
same time is to drink liquid Death
Mountain Spring Water liquid death
sparkling mountain spring water liquid
death flavored sparkling water I mean
what's great about this company is not
just the water's so great but the water
comes in
infinitely recyclable tall boy cans
which are designed to look like beers
plus the company hates plastic liquid
death that's a whole reason they're
called liquid death they want to bring
death to plastic why because plastic is
destroying the world we know that
infinitely recyclable aluminum is not
destroying the world and that's why
these cool beer looking tall boys of
liquid Death Mountain spring water are
the coolest the healthiest and the best
for the environment and you can get them
online without paying anything for
shipping water's pretty heavy and
shipping it costs a lot but not for you
if you go to
liquiddeath.com
Stevo plus you know you're helping me
out you're helping me out if you do that
and you're helping the world out if you
do that you're helping yourself out if
you do that so let's do that go to
liquiddeath.com
slash Devo for all of your water and
merch the whole order no shipping you
don't pay anything for shipping man what
a deal jump on it and let's talk about
this guy's brain
and I just oh that's right we hadn't you
had brain surgery I had brain surgery
and they took out a golf ball sized
piece of my brain and it was from my
right frontal lobe
and I was born with an AVM which is an
arterial venous malformation and it's
just a malformed part of your brain that
never really develops it's just a mess
of arteries and veins
that you don't use but it is
um
it's prone to hemorrhaging it's like
more fragile than the rest of your brain
but what's weird and again I just didn't
talk about this for a long time because
I didn't want to make it a part of my
identity I guess was the reason I didn't
or I didn't want to be honest with
myself that I was brain damaged or as my
neuropsychologist says I had a traumatic
brain injury
um do you know what the injury was so it
wasn't you're born with it okay so yeah
Birds was the injury the worst of all
because you never recover from it right
um and so
um and so I what happens with the brain
is because I don't have the same amount
of brain matter as the two of you the
rest is the elasticity of the brain it's
such an amazing organ
um
all the other parts of my brain picked
up the slack and so I seem act and think
as if I'm a regular person like right
now you got but what's different is I'm
prone to Mania and so
um what somebody who is bipolar feels I
don't feel the depression side of that
but I can tip my way into the Mania
do you get manic at all yeah sometimes
and when I do it's [ __ ] creepy as
hell dude it's crazy and so do you know
what is happening
um it's hard to tell until you're in it
and then when you're in it it's you're
so far gone that you're just like yeah
this is amazing my mind has reached a
different this is the greatest City I've
ever had in my life 100 I'm gonna start
I'm gonna work on the computer while I'm
doing this thing I'm gonna be uh no I
gotta write I gotta write so then you
write like 50 pages 100 pages and then
you stop you're like okay I'll get back
to this oh I gotta be making food while
I'm doing it's just it's so I've never
done cocaine but people say it's like
that but it's not because because you're
not on drugs there's no way for you to
be like maybe it's the drugs
I had a like a surgery recently the one
that I said that was the highest I've
been like that yeah I just saw that
video that that triggered some crazy
Mania in me like you weren't I didn't
see I've seen it other size before and I
I you were [ __ ] up but it wasn't like
I think it was just no sleep [ __ ] up
like I didn't see anything wow about it
so that's the big thing and this is what
you heard and and said which is like
something where you're on a train or
something so I had a manic episode on
the train and what happens is because of
my condition I have to get eight or nine
hours of sleep a night oh wow if I don't
sleep for an entire night it's very
dangerous and the other thing that's
dangerous is combination so five hours
of sleep having a bunch of drinks
being dehydrated right smoking pot
that's too strong keeps me up I only get
three hours of sleep then all those
things can kind of I start to get my
feet in Mania and what I've talked to my
neuropsychologist about recently like in
the last week or two is that I have to
just be honest with myself that Mania is
fun it can be fun and so it's sort of
addictive in that way where you're like
maybe I'll have another shot and just
stay up a little bit longer and see if I
could just just get there and then it's
like and then he goes goes goes goes
Mania is your drug of choice kind of yes
and the way to get there is lack of
sleep
um also if you have extreme emotional
swings things that are happening like
that that can also trigger it and that's
what happened on the train is that I had
been going I had been totally Sleepless
I had this whole situation where
this uh you know it's just I I had the
internet absolutely attacking me and I
had it feeling like the world so I was
gonna spin out no matter what and the
problem is the way that I spin out used
to be like this I'm sure also was to
kind of turn to drugs and alcohol to
kind of mollify that like ah and that
instead of like making me be like hold
on gasoline on the fire and and so then
what happened was item manic episode on
the train there
I sort of believed that this woman was
dangerous and which translates to other
like well women can be dangerous and
women that you don't know can do awful
things and all this kind of so that was
all in my brain and
um and then I thought New Yorker I'm
very proud of living in New York City I
was like well if you see something say
something so I want to be a good New
Yorker and so I saw something I said
something and I want to let you guys
know if it's not anything it'll be
something okay oh it'll be saying for a
while it'll be everything uh but that in
my mind it was all real it's all real
that I'm hoping that this woman deserves
that we've call this out and make sure
that she's not being dangerous and all
this stuff
and so it was a misunderstanding with
the federal government they eventually
dismissed it because they understood for
sure they're like okay if this is where
he can get to I had evaluations by all
these doctors but what it did was great
is I found this neuropsychologist who
explained to me you had this surgery in
2010 and they didn't have the thing that
you needed it didn't exist then what I
needed was called cognitive remediation
and it's where you go back and you teach
yourself to do the things that other
people do cognitively
um without thinking about it down
regulate I don't know what is that it's
just like talking yourself down in a
healthy manner
I mean I know we haven't used that like
like I don't I don't have it like if I
get frustrated I'm just like oh and I
had like normal people are just like
okay cool it's not that big of a deal
but I don't have that there would be
that it's also things like looking at
your schedule for the next day
or like
um what are some other examples of it
just like like looking at me this is all
real looking in the mirror and seeing do
I have physical signs of being tired
because I never feel tired oh my God I
feel tired of time he's like I'm always
[ __ ] tired it's the worst it's the
second worst I don't have that and so
never will I be like and so that's why
I'm kind of this Indie fatigueable just
never exhausted work ethic that I just
constantly and it's driven also by
wanting to make people feel good wanting
to make them laugh because I think life
is so [ __ ] tragic you know from
almost every angle sure and so and are
you know the reason I like circus
because no matter what you're doing you
tune into something Stevo's doing right
now and you're like everything's gone
you're just like is he going to die type
thing yeah and and also you know when
you're a great Storyteller a person just
lets everything go and sits in the story
if you've got a joke that's gonna make
so I love doing that so much and so I
just thought well I should just work as
hard as I can until I die Ai and I had
to sort of learn not to do that so
that's that that's been really helpful
for me because now I recognize it I can
tell and yeah
like it's been a long time since like
that any of that has been in the
Consciousness oh yeah right like uh yeah
I think so and I think the other thing
is is that um
it's a shame that I didn't have a forum
then to talk about mental illness and
it's also it's not just mental illness
it's like brain damage you know and what
that can leave you with when you're
trying to figure it out isn't that funny
are you brain damaged at all ah not that
I'm aware of like I like to be the women
you would think it would be the absolute
opposite that he would be brain damaged
and I wouldn't well right now like with
the CTE thing they can't find out if you
have it until you're dead and they like
can look at your brain so I mean I'm a
little bit of a question mark in that
regard yeah well and the nitrous oxide
was completely because it was a Slowdown
I would never do cocaine or amphetamines
or anything like that because I don't
need to go that direction I don't drink
coffee I don't do any of that stuff
um but nitrous was so effective at
bringing it down so I was probably in a
manic State when I hosted the Critics
Choice Awards the second one and so to
sort of bring that Mania down I would do
nitrous because then it would be gone
because drinking that is depressed and
it works but you can't become undrunk
like right 15 minutes later did you ever
start hearing voices when you're doing
nitrous a little bit like The psychosis
yeah because they're it can get pretty
bad when I stopped was when because you
do build a tolerance for it and I
stopped when I was like this just isn't
it's not bringing me down enough right
but it still like gives you a headaches
or it's crazy well you did it for a long
time I did a lot of it man I did a lot
of it it really messed me up I think
what there's a like a study done by the
voices in your head uh per like based on
the continent you're from like the
psychosis some some countries are like a
woman's voice some countries are a men's
voice
like I had a whole committee
I'm surprised you don't have nerve
damage that was another problem but um I
yeah I would hear sort of Echo and then
realize it's not my voice that's pretty
[ __ ] scary dude I had one of my
voices there was someone who's in
transition I think I don't really yeah I
don't Define genders right now this is
2022. right okay they identified as they
them yeah yeah exactly is that they have
boys one of my voices was Tommy Lee
they're very distinctly yeah dude it's
like yeah another whippy [ __ ] yeah dude
it was the most distinct time really and
uh yeah I I I I I I I remember wanting
to reach out to me like dude this is
really amazing and he was like it was
like he's at a computer station yeah
she's hiding behind your fans again
all right dude yeah anybody else that
you like identify ah what's up I don't
remember any like celebrities there's
certainly like personal friends all
kinds of them yeah like
um it was Wild and the thing was that I
loved it dude yeah it's a great drug I
tell you that all the time it is a great
drug but your upside of the high just
immediately goes away after a year or
something like that or two years how
long did you do it uh off and on for a
long time yeah I'd go through phases of
it but but dude everything you were just
telling us was [ __ ] fascinating man
yeah it's very it's very bizarre and
yeah and and almost like as I like asked
that as we were telling all that stories
I almost felt like man I've you know put
TJ in and like like a an uncomfortable
spot but I also was so fascinated by it
you know and I'm gonna talk about it in
my next special I have a a story about
it from this is not happening at Comedy
Central at a show it's called TJ uh
Miller has a seizure but you know now
I'm on medication and have been since
2010 and that's permanent and so and and
what I found out was that I used to be
on Keppra and now I'm on this uh this
medication vimpat which is sort of the
Next Generation but after Keppra after I
changed the medication we were talking
to my neurologist and Kate said so were
there any like side effects that we that
he had from Keppra that that he and the
my doctor was like oh yeah
what do you mean he goes oh yeah
definitely
he has Moon instability impulse control
problems that's a big one I mean name
really sings and Kate was like uh that's
been the problem okay and you know his
attitude was like yeah but if he didn't
take it he would die so why would I tell
you oh watch out for these side effects
because that's him other easy they're
dead or he's this guy
and so that was the thing too is nobody
knew that no employer would ever have
been like well he has impulse control
problems so if he's gonna like you know
decide to eat everything in the craft
service table is a joke then get sick
then that's kind of what he's gonna do I
guess we got to just watch out for that
so I never had any of that so there's
another thing that's weird which is like
I think people had this concept of me
being kind of a crazy guy but what they
didn't understand was that was it was a
physical thing it was kind of I was sort
of because when I when I first found out
about the AVM I was filming Yogi Bear 3D
it's a children's movie
the first time he found out about the
adult video
isn't it the AVN Awards yeah
it almost won a BBN award which was uh
bear bear in his videos and uh and so
um and so I was out there and I'm taught
I'm playing Ranger Jones so I'm human
the Bears are CGI I'm out there in New
Zealand so it was a live action movie
yeah it's a live action and cartoon
hybrid and it's kind of like Roger
Rabbit yeah and so I'm there and
where I'm I'm depressed me and uh me and
one of the other stars drinking all the
time all the time and it's on the other
side of the world so my schedule so I
just stop sleeping and I started to go
crazy I didn't know it but I was became
obsessed with entanglement puzzles and
which are like you know the Horseshoe
the two horseshoes with the ring and you
gotta try and
so that and then I started to kind of
think my mind had elevated and I was
somehow smarter than everybody else not
like I'm sorry I just had gotten to a
different plane and that I would I would
hear voices I had a tough time going to
sleep
um so I had to listen to Morgan Murphy
who's this comedian and she would talk
and I was sorry and I really started
believing I narrated my own conversation
so I if I was at that point I would come
in and I'd be like all right I'm gonna
start with a compliment to you but I'm
gonna make my way to talk about how his
hoodie seems like a mistake but kind of
helps balance out the two of us and then
I'm going to connect our experiences as
clowns and then we're gonna sort of do a
clown bit type thing and I'll I'll bring
that all back to the comment that you've
got so go ahead thank you yeah and so I
would do that and then I brought these
two girls from the Liverpool England I
met them on chat roulette and I flew
them to New Zealand and they stayed with
me uh for the rest of the movie and it
wasn't like a um sexual thing I I just
brought them to bring a new Fresh
perspective to the movie Set so that
everybody could see the movie Through
The Eyes of people that weren't sort of
bogged down by it because it took
forever it was a really hard movie to
shoot everything so it's doing all this
stuff and then I came back and I did so
much [ __ ] nitrous because at that
point I Had a Brain Hemorrhage a very
small bleed so there's over activity
specifically in this part of my head
which is the one that works on language
and all that kind of stuff and I was
going so fast I couldn't sleep so it's
just doing nitrous all the time all the
time morning to night constantly
spending thousands of dollars on Nitro
stock because it costs about a dollar
for a cartridge so it's like the most
expensive High you could ever imagine
last year like what 30 seconds no it's
one hit you just do one cartridge
completely and you were doing like the
uh uh yeah yeah the the whipped cream
dispensers I got really good at like
having two of the dispensers so I'm like
I really like filling them up like going
back I got to a point where I could just
about not breathe in anything except
nitrous oxide oh because yeah if you
hold your breath you get to the
exclusion of oxygen yeah but I would
that's insane that I wasn't doing it
was your goal to what's called fish out
where you lose Consciousness and you're
like flopping around like a fish no I
think that's a major difference between
you and me that's what that's all I
wanted and I would be holding my breath
and holding sucking in more and like
riding around the floor like I'd be mad
at myself like if I couldn't hold my
breath until I lost Consciousness and
flopped around like I wouldn't know
you're doing this no but I would find
out when I woke up and I'd be like yes
really dude you are so [ __ ] hardcore
no but I would do the two dispensers at
once and do both them at once or one of
the other but I'd read somewhere that
the oxygen nitrous cut if the Dennis
office gives you is 70 30
and so I would try and kind of gauge
that I'd sort of do it and then yeah
regular air in there yeah it was
ridiculous
um but yeah I mean you know it's like a
dollar a cartridge so for an afternoon
you can spend hundreds and hundreds of
dollars it's a bad drug to have
unlimited money yeah you can be able to
buy as much as you want yeah where do
you buy this [ __ ] at at the smoke shops
and then they become dealers and you
kind of go in there and they give you a
better price for the 100 packs and I
would get a case of the 24 boxes
25 per case so it's I think that comes
to 600. yeah exactly and I had I found a
place I could buy them online and Kate
got so mad at me once because she came
and she like was like these two boxes
came from there so heavy and I it took
me forever to get them up and she's like
what are in this and I had forgotten and
I was like I don't know you didn't
forget and she saw it she goes this is
all nitrous oxide and I was like oh yeah
it's for us
I thought we would enjoy she's like what
the [ __ ] are you doing anniversary right
exactly no I mean you know it's I would
also do [ __ ] on nitrous if you're like
in it you start to kind of fall that's
having me instead of fishing out I would
fog out right right right I didn't get
like foggy right and and you write
regrettable emails yeah for sure often
to myself it's just like go cancel this
order that you sent to your white studio
uh yeah I mean it was so I got back from
Yogi Bear 3D was just crushing
cartridges Non-Stop and then I had the
seizure and then another seizure and
when I got there they did a scan and
they're like you have an AVM which is
something we usually find at autopsy so
most people they only find it after
they're dead and um and so I was really
really lucky and it was Cedar Sinai
which is the great Hospital yeah and
they performed surgery they embolized it
and then you know removed it and I I
remember they were like this is in 2010
yeah so that's that's the brain surgery
that was the brain surgery it was like
so do you have a killer scars and under
your hair yeah it's under my hair but
it's yeah I have if you I can't entirely
in a mirror but it's yeah there's a scar
that goes from here all the way down and
he's doing a movie where I shave my head
and look like an insane person because
that would be a good it's a good look
for a villain
um but I I went in and they said look
this we do this surgery but one out of
ten people that do it die
and that's just kind of Statistics we
just have to tell you that it's a 10
fatality rate but if you didn't get the
surgery so I asked I said well will I
still be funny after the surgery and the
doctor was like what he's like what are
you talking about I was like well that's
kind of my livelihood and it's also it's
what I do it's what makes life worth
living for me is making other people
laugh so really it's really funny and
he's like
I mean I think so because you're not
really using that part of your brain so
yeah I guess and like okay and I go what
happens if I don't get the surgery he's
like well you probably die when you're
in your mid-30s like 35 and I was like
Gambling Man let's roll the dice you
know and now I'm here and you guys have
better hot sauce for it you know yeah
dude made it made it through that and
then took the Keppra
which is that one made me crazy uh
mildly crazy and then I got off of it
because they told me it was elective so
I just stopped taking it for like 11
days man that's this doctor that didn't
tell you about the side effects and it
said if you would die if you didn't take
it now you learn it's elective well so
here's what it was he he that this was
before he said so he goes it's elective
his name is Dr stokel he's the best
neurologist maybe in the world he's
world renowned and he said it's elective
you don't have to take it but you should
and so then I decided five years later
I'm gonna stop taking it and I had a
seizure in like two weeks you know so
then he said to me when he saw me again
he goes okay now you're there's a
percentage of people that they have to
take Keppra and it's a smaller
percentage so you're in the small
percentage that didn't die you're in the
smaller percentage that has to say
Kepler or you will die and so that's
kind of where you are so I actually in
that world I'm like
like a case study because I also become
incredibly successful while still having
this AVM condition and I'm probably I'm
I am I'm the most high profile person
with this type of brain damage
um but it's it's been so good now I mean
the train thing was so awful for so many
reasons but I was so yeah that was like
five years ago yeah it was a while ago
yeah and it's but I was so lucky to find
this cognitive remediation this was you
know the psychologist this
neuropsychologist who said we've really
got to help you learn how to do the
things that other people do without
thinking yeah and so as she's helped me
do that it's gotten a lot better and I
worked for so long
I'm gonna ask you about this I worked
for so long with the brain damage using
alcohol to bring using nitrous oxide to
bring the Mania down also using it to
trigger Mania so that I could get more
and more work done that I had to learn
how to work without feeling like I need
to do this this that I got to stay up I
can't go to sleep I gotta did you feel
like you had to do that when you sort of
got completely sober I had to just put
work aside and just make make sobriety
the only priority for me and I did that
for for really like the first two years
you know it was really fortunate that
you could do that yeah with some
exceptions but uh what about your life
that you need to work on for two years
like was it just basic functions of like
what a normal like what what were you
working on in that two years putting
everything aside except for just uh like
we're getting routines figuring out I
had to I had to put down on the camera I
had to just not be an attention [ __ ] I
had to like just
commit myself to
spiritual practice and figuring out what
that means like uh remember you always
went to bed when we first met you always
made your bed and you're up by nine yeah
that's a big thing right yeah was that
like because because I don't do that
still and I'm like okay was it stuff
like that like okay yeah and that's some
structure and and discipline and just
sobriety and you know like I I had
really humiliated myself in in my run
with drugs and alcohol particularly
towards the end and uh that accumulation
I really like hung on to it as like
motivation to just take sobriety so
seriously and and once I had a
foundation in sobriety then I uh and
integrated all the attention horn back
into my life
and so I it was I was yeah that's what
I'm saying was it hard to go back to
performing without being on drugs wasn't
hard at all like uh the the absence of
the drugs wasn't you know if anything I
I I I
came to learn that the drugs and alcohol
weren't all they had done was it was
just
it was an impediment to it you know like
like coming back into the attention
[ __ ] business clean and sober I think I
I was way more effective way more
creative like and managing like what was
the first thing you did back was it the
Dancing with the Stars Dancing with the
Stars I was one year sober so that I I
kind of don't even count that what about
jackass jackass 3D we were just had
begun filming it when I turned two years
over okay but nothing in between the
first year did you I didn't do [ __ ] I I
volunteered at a nursing home
yes I uh I I I led games of bingo for
really old people in a nursing home did
anybody know who you were
no I don't think so I love that that's
really good and then when you went to
Jackass 3D was it hard that you were now
sober and other people weren't or were
they [ __ ] because in my mind I wanted to
ask you this in my mind those are the
guys that would be like not that they're
Bad Dudes those are guys would be like
here I have a cup of tea and it's just
like loaded with [ __ ] bugs no no
those guys took it so [ __ ] seriously
like they they uh it was like it was
like a tricep Steve was sober you we
respect that you know like you can't you
know and and uh there are a couple
people that drank on set anyway but you
know like uh that's great that's what I
think that they would have done so that
really wasn't hard at all for you
sobriety it was not not at all it was uh
yeah the guys were so supportive and it
makes sense that they that they should
have been so supportive because God was
a [ __ ] nightmare when I was yeah that
was the other side I was a lot easier
they were like dang yeah yeah for sure
and my relationships with all of those
guys improved just dramatically because
I was clean and sober it was I was just
a lot
easier to be around yeah what do you do
when fans are like take a shot take a
shot with me just say hey I'm so right I
didn't know they're like I'm your
biggest fan dude will you take a shot
with me it's like we'll be my biggest
fan you would know I'm 15 years sober oh
yeah 14 years yeah there you go I mean I
wouldn't even I would never say that but
uh I mean I don't know I I
I don't take uh you know do a shot with
me very seriously it doesn't affect me
too much yeah I just was interested in
yeah and I think that it just kind of as
a rule in uh you know the community of
sober people who really like kind of
take it seriously like
um we
have our things that we do to kind of
protect our sobriety so that all these
things that aren't too big of a deal
yeah and then do you do you go to
meetings did you take it out right yeah
I mean I do like we don't necessarily
talk about it at a public level much but
yeah I don't ever want to go like a week
without doing that so yeah yeah I asked
my sister is like she's a daily meeting
right okay no matter where she is right
so it's interested in that too but I
think you know I Nikki Glaser is a good
friend of mine and she kind of quit
drinking and it just it helped her so
much you know what I mean and I think
what I realized I used to drink so much
but it was because of the Mania and the
and so now that I'm not like on that I
don't need it in that way it's just it's
really improved my life because I'm not
like drunk the only real problem I ever
had I didn't find and Santa
so I never got hungover
so I never understood maybe I've been
hungover like
10 times in my life and so everybody
else wakes up and they're like oh my God
that's the worst I feel like [ __ ] and I
would wake up and be like all right
let's go what do we want to do have a
couple beers and then let's head to the
day so that was the problem with that
manic energy is it could just blow
through I'm also the medication I take
makes me very thirsty so I'm always way
more hydrated than than other people I
think that helps too but that was weird
I really didn't realize that until a
year or two ago
that people would say ah it's so great
because now I don't drink and I wake up
and I don't have a hangover right I was
like what do you mean like I didn't that
just didn't track for me so yeah over
yeah yeah I'm gonna hang under it
um so yeah it was you know those so that
that type of drinking and that type of
drug use the nitrous and everything that
was definitely I think an impediment the
problem is now I'm trying to learn how
to work at that speed but safely and
without using alcohol or weed to like
because for a long time I was like
smoked weed every day most of the day
and it would either get me manic or it
would chill me out and have to be manic
depending on who's an indica or sativa
so not having to
base any kind of drug use or having
drinks or anything on medicating a brain
injury
now my life is like so different yeah
were you really blazing it like taking
bong loads in Silicon Valley
sometimes I kind of you know I left that
show after four
seasons in part because no one is ever
like my favorite season of Breaking Bad
season seven
yeah now when after a show goes four or
five seasons
it doesn't get better that's why they
say jump the shark you know so we got to
that point also I was kind of on
autopilot it wasn't interesting to me
and I knew the characters so well and
we'd done so much with that it was so
[ __ ] it was so funny I was I'd gotten
to a point where I was kind of yeah I
could totally go in and do I would
always get high when I was done with my
coverage I would just smoke and I feel
like your character would like take
action like bong loads on the show were
you so that is a Hollywood weed but you
never did really yeah I'd throw in there
you know what I mean and uh and so but I
would um I feel like nobody else in the
[ __ ] world could have played that
role dude like you you were so goddamn
genius in that thank you man yeah it was
I mean that's all my judge I just talked
to Jimmy oh yeah a couple days ago we
live in the same city and I always like
pass them on the street but I never say
what's up really you gotta see what's up
I mean nicest guy I'm just like it's a
such a fan of you on that show thank you
man yeah I mean I'm about to maybe do
this Christmas movie where I think no
one else can play Santa in the way Santa
I love it yeah it's gonna be great but
yeah it's you know I I would smoke a
little bit but I said I gotta I have to
take her off and do something else it's
the same reason like after Deadpool 2 I
was like I can't do this character again
if he had his own movie or something but
I've sort of done this character and
then people be like okay I can't believe
you're not gonna do Deadpool 3 wedge and
I always say
um have you seen hangover three
and like oh yeah and I'm like didn't it
kind of taint hangover one and there was
like yeah yeah so I also think being in
the third sequel of anything you know
being a third installment of a franchise
it's a problem you know only in Marvel
has it they've been able to sort it out
that got pretty bad too Police Academy
got pretty bad Jaws got pretty bad The
Godfather Three wasn't a great yeah
because it always feels like a cash grab
because that's what it is yeah you know
the story has been told the story that
could have been out first told maybe you
do a prequel and that's interesting but
the third horror movie some I mean you
know [ __ ] you just reminded me that
we've got a new house of the Dragon
what's that that prequel to Game of
Thrones Sunday nights right see I can't
Kate I Love Game of Thrones until the
dragons
we just were like we're not dungeons
drag we like the power of struggle yeah
whatever but then when fake dragons come
in we kind of lost interest but you love
it I mean like I did when the dragons
are flying across the screen yeah it's a
little bit whack but it is so fun though
it doesn't ruin the whole thing for me
yeah it is so so fun I love that you
loved Silicon Valley both of you oh my
God so we were on tour together and it
was just like [ __ ] it couldn't get it
yeah it's a it was a fun show yeah it's
really really good you said something
earlier about like it sounded like uh as
you've gone through you've become more
famous yeah like uh that that's rad like
you've got like huge projects and still
more huge projects in the in the works
yeah I'm just looking at the list of
things that I wanted to talk to you
about
um yeah I mean I think we're all ready
uh officially the longest episode we've
ever recorded that's amazing it's
amazing that's true it's amazing
so here they go they get it yeah like
look I love it and so I um uh yeah we
have this Christmas movie idea that's
amazing me and my buddy it's his idea we
wrote it together we just pitched it to
the Russo Brothers I talked to Michael
Bay yesterday we're going to Miami this
weekend nice trying to nail him down
he's so he's so funny our texting is
like
to like junior high students that like
each other but don't you know what I
mean it's like he'll ghost me if I make
fun of him like wait a while and they'll
try and hit me back and make fun of me
but he's a good dude I like him a lot I
like what I heard about him and he just
has crates of GoPros on the set he just
like yeah totally he's the craziest I
mean he's so ridiculous to work with and
he's always screaming through it but
he's actually really really funny and
he's really really sweet and so who he
is when he's working and the reputation
he has
Kate's never seen him on set so she's
like he's the sweetest guy and I'm like
yeah but he's really he's it could be a
nightmare on set if he wants to be and
she's like I just don't see it I just
can't imagine but he came to a show of
mine in uh like near Hollywood Florida
so I'm going out of Miami that's where
he lives so I think my buddy's coming
with me we're gonna pitch to him and
then uh Seth MacFarlane's company we're
gonna go the first week of October and
Pitch to them I mean yeah
Michael Bay making a Santa movie it it
seems counterintuitive whereas Seth
MacFarlane making a really irreverent
Santa movie with TJ Miller like I can
so I can't I can't give it away that
makes more sense the Russo Brothers
really but it's like
this is why we picture the Russo
Brothers it's like Marvel Avengers end
game level Christmas movies is that
insane so it's slow and I can't because
the whole thing of the movie is like the
conceit of it so I can't give you the
elevator pitch on the podcast but that's
the main thing that we're working on
from that perspective because and what's
funny about going and pitching this is
at the end of it I'm like
so in this movie I'm going to play kind
of a version of Santa Claus if you're
concerned about me starring in a
Christmas movie of Santa Claus look no
further in my resume to when I starred
in a Christmas movie as Santa Claus in
office Christmas party and so it's
really a weird thing where I'm saying I
have another Christmas movie but it's
PG-13 and it's bigger it's big all right
biggest so that's kind of thing I'm
working there and then I did this I
wrote this um
this show it's like a limited series I
might do it just as a movie it's called
The Loneliest Megaplex and it's about
the pandemic it's like in June 2020
Summer 2020 they opened up movie
theaters but nobody was seeing movies
and so in this I get hired back to my
job at the movie theater but I'm the
only one they hire so I'm the
concessions guy ticket taker manager
janitor everything it's a 30 screen
Megaplex and each episode is the one
person or a couple people that come in
to see a movie that day and it's super
funny but it's super sad like I did
these two
um Sundance shorts one was called
successful alcoholics and the other was
called I'm having a difficult time
killing my parents
yeah I didn't try and kill my parents
um
this has not been shot this the
loneliest Megaplex not yet no because it
just struck me I was like I had the
thought wow the loneliest face it seems
weird to make a sort of retroactively a
movie about the heat of the pandemic or
a series but then I thought what if uh
when you make it what what if it was
more of a more futuristic and it's like
here in in the year
2030 and the next pandemic comes but
it's like the most [ __ ] lethal virus
that the pandemic is so like so it's
like even like bump it up a bunch of
notches for like the pandemic where
people are really freaking yeah and that
could be a Flash Forward you know what I
mean yeah it's also one where I'm in the
movie theater and nobody comes for like
a week or something so I started to go
crazy and so that could be a fever dream
of like what it'll be like in 2030
exactly
um but yeah so I love that and it's kind
of like those Sundance shorts that I did
which you can see online and um they are
they're are funny but there are comedies
of substance is what I call it pun
intended on the alcoholic one but like
it's um it's just they're real they're
sad but they're hilarious you know so
that's what the loneliest Megaplex I
think is going to be but the biggest
thing is this shooting is special dear
Jonah and shooting philosophy circus
like I haven't done a special a long
time but what I've been doing where
you're pouring the water up so that's
called meticulously ridiculous so I did
that one that's that was a while ago it
was like six years ago and then before
that I did one for Comedy Central called
uh no real reason
um but this is like these are the first
stand-up specials that I shot after I
was touring is just a stand-up because
so often I was getting so much acting
work that I was just slotting and stand
up and I got in trouble on Silicon
Valley for that too I would work for 14
hours then go and that night everybody
else would go home and go to sleep or
look at their lines for the next day
I would go straight out and do two shows
three shows hang out afterwards talk
shop go home go to sleep at two wake up
at five a.m for the call on Monday to go
and do that and that was just the
schedule that I was doing and because I
don't get tired I would start to get
Manic and then once I had a psychotic
episode and that was like have you ever
had one of these that had some nitrous
involved for sure but that was also
alcohol and marijuana but that was one
where I thought that the birds were
drones from the government I thought the
Chinese government was watching me
through the camera I smashed my computer
because I was sure of it I remember this
is very real to me to this day I was a
website was loading and it just said
visit China go to China China China
Chinese tourism come to China and it
would load in between and I was like the
Chinese government is clearly trying to
get me to go to China and it's real I
remember exactly what it looked like it
can't be real but it's definitely an
actual a memory that I have and then you
have that classic things you ever have
this it almost seems kind of hack as
it's happening but where the television
is talking to you did you ever have that
I had that on mushrooms once a Baywatch
that's slightly better than mine mine
was the news and they were like it's
your fault I I had that with music a
song where it all of a sudden start
saying things to me but I don't remember
a TV I remember looking at a carpet and
the carpet uh like the the what do you
call it the bristles of the carpet like
just took its own form and it turned
into a pornographic scene the the carpet
itself was a porno in it and how was the
porno it was uh just so wild that it was
a porno like I couldn't really evaluate
like the quality of this yeah you're
probably too hard to even find your
penis that way uh yeah I it was so weird
but you watched the news and they are
talking to you and they're giving kind
of secret messages to you and I had read
about that and that's why I thought it
was so hacked but when it's happening
you're like this is happening this is
actually happening so I had to I didn't
go into work
um Silicon Valley the next day because
that would have been an actual disaster
and that's I think when Mike Judge
because years later he would say
um because we're still friends but years
later you'd be like yeah just TJ kind of
seemed like he didn't want to be there
and that wasn't the case it was so much
the case that I loved the show I was
just running myself into the ground and
kind of having this brain condition all
the while and so that has been that so
that was that's like how bad it can get
you know but now thankfully I haven't
had any kind of psychotic split or
anything like that since the train
incident okay it's been really really
good and mostly it has to do with this
cognitive remediation about just
planning it sounds insane but it's like
Kate and I will be like
so let's like I don't know let's go get
a couple drinks we have a few glasses of
wine then let's try and leave by like
nine o'clock
and then it's fine but we never would
talk about that beforehand and she's
also kind of crazy and so things just
would get out of hand then we would want
to hang out with each other and stay up
all night and then I would have to leave
at seven in the morning to go and all of
that I was just doing and thinking it
was fine and it's actually really really
dangerous so the stress of spot Nanny
like is it like that's what
kind of gets you there is like if you
plan it out like your brain is like okay
there's some structure but if you're
like
do you maybe you get stressed out if
you're just like okay [ __ ] it let's just
go and see what happens well I think
what it's really it's so much about
sleep I mean I think people you know use
I'm sure when you saw the stuff going on
with me you were immediately like whoa
this is a serious drug alcohol situation
yeah but it was so much more about sleep
and so if I had just like paid attention
but I couldn't sleep because I thought
that the world was attacking me because
someone had lied about something because
they're mentally ill and that's kind of
all I'll say about that but it was I it
was so insane to feel like all of
Twitter and the world hated you and
believed this thing about you and so I
just couldn't sleep it's just the worst
thing in the world if I ever went on the
internet people like TJ Miller is the
worst person in the world I wish she was
dead and so because of that
you start spinning you'd sleep with us
you sleep less and then you start to get
manic so what do you do I need to have a
couple drinks we're on the train let's
just have a couple drinks I can't you
know what I need to sleep I'm gonna
sleep I'm gonna do that I have a drink
and I'm gonna sleep
you know I probably shouldn't sleep I
just need it because I really got to
think about you know what I should be
working right now and is that just like
a train it's kind of The Locomotion of
it is go faster faster faster and then
click the track Clicks in and you can't
stop and so it goes all the way I'm
lucky that it wasn't like
alcoholism thing where I was driving
drunk and hit a kid you know what I mean
and I know that you've talked about your
experience with drinking and driving
you're not proud of it but I love how
you talk about it and I love that video
of all your arrests I really like that
because I like you you are so
interesting as a performer as a maniac
as a stunt man
um as a comedian all of those things
it's a clown okay but more interesting
is you now and seeing your you know
hindsight and your retrospective and
being able to have it's fascinating
because you're the same person but it's
you're talking about a completely
different person and then I always think
about this and that person had no idea
right about you at the time had no idea
you exist or that you were going to be
the whole deal what Heights you were
going to get to so I think that's really
really amazing and I just feel lucky
that I didn't get into a situation where
I right but you don't have a manic
episode and like
go out and hit a kid and while in
Silicon Valley I know I hit a kid and I
called him a [ __ ] but it's in general
the manic episode is more about
psychology and getting out so this the
split the big problem is you completely
distancing yourself from reality and so
in that world being helpful ends up
being dangerous type of thing sure uh
yeah so it's but the spontaneity I
understand what you're saying yeah and I
don't think it stresses me out to
um like structure my life but it's
really
um it's really hard for me it's just it
doesn't come naturally in any way shape
or form and you know what you're talking
about it's like for alcoholics or drug
addicts sometimes it is about structure
get up make the bed right about this
coffee is from here to here I'm going to
a meeting at this time yeah and so you
know lots of people have problems with
that it's just I needed somebody to like
sit with me and help me understand I
mean it doesn't maybe it sounds crazy
maybe it doesn't but to me how insane is
it that to understand if I'm tired I
have to look at myself
I think
this this whoop band it gives you all of
your uh information about your sleep
all right yeah it's great right you like
the whooping I love the whoop band yeah
this is a ring and it does I think
essentially the same stuff like like how
long you're in bed how much of that time
you were asleep yeah like uh each stage
is yeah like the percentage of it super
helpful so so without being able to
determine uh based on your the way you
feel you can have like the actual
analytics so that's exactly what this is
and the aura ring does Readiness in the
morning and that's like how well your
sleep is and how what you should be
planning on for the day so that's
helpful but I'm the same way as you I
love saying like Okay this was this much
REM this was this much deep sleep I need
more deep sleep what can I do what did I
do that night oh we got a massage before
we went to sleep okay so yeah sauna do
we get in the hot tub or whatever it was
that happened to happen
and also it's you know stuff like and
everybody should be doing this but uh
not looking at a screen for like a half
right before you go to sleep which is
really really hard to do
yeah are those glasses you're wearing
like blue they look like blue blocking
glasses no but they're great because
they get rid of they mute all the
fluorescence all the artificial lights
yeah exactly blocking out the haters hey
uh dude they keep texting me saying
somebody's waiting to get in here at two
o'clock
I feel so bad because
things that I wanted to ask you yeah
please maybe you guys will have me back
what did you think of this it's
important I don't know I went straight
to [ __ ] sand loved it good yeah I
loved it best Everyday Use and this is
just great did you try this with the
papaya I I didn't I only had so good
Insanity I love it all
um and they can get those at uh your
website yes TJ Miller does not have a
website.com and I'm gonna hook you up
with our Amazon people if you want to
get this on Amazon yeah that would be
amazing that would be really really
great
um I so you have a hip-hop album I did
put out a hip-hop mixtape it is
fascinating so I have a hip-hop album
It's like a fake one also but it's
called the extended play ep the sad
thing is that I I didn't realize it was
fake at the time
I'm just talking about mine I said I
have a fake also I just met in addition
to my other work you guys should do
another song together we really should
oh dude I would love that but I really
really I did it it's an EP but it's 41
track some of the tracks are less than
six seconds left 41 tracks so yeah so I
was wondering about that but yeah let's
switch numbers we'll collab on a wrap so
let's do it I love your MP TV cribs I
just want to say it was so absolutely
hilarious because you look like I'm
dressed like a teenage millionaire you
look like just a hood rat millionaire I
mean it was so amazing and then I just
wanted to finish by saying I'm not
allowed to perform in Terrebonne Parish
Louisiana anymore either wow wow we'll
talk about that next time there are a
couple of counties yep certainly
Louisiana I've done some crazy [ __ ]
Louisiana I wish that uh I think
Louisiana is the only state that doesn't
have the term County they have the term
Parish which is I mean I wish it was
just called Terrebonne County it would
be so much more meaningful to explain my
lifetime ban
yeah right exactly but you know it's
kind of funny it's a parish it seems
even more like religiously yeah it's
almost satanic yeah what you've done
here is too close to Satan never come
back it's got a it's got a religious
connotations and yeah dude [ __ ] like
this has been Now by far the longest uh
episode of The Wild Ride podcast we've
ever recorded and what an honored to do
it with you it's been such a wild ride
more to come yeah thank you man yeah
another pleasure dude awesome there you
have it one of my new favorite guys and
officially the longest episode of The
Wild Ride podcast ever recorded that son
of a [ __ ] was so long that our uh
beloved podcast Guru got his dream come
true four sponsors never done that
before
the head that's what happens when you
got a [ __ ] damn near two hour long
podcast you got more room for sponsors
uh God I'm exhausted I'm [ __ ]
absolutely [ __ ] exhausted I love you
guys I'm going to bed